genius is an amorphous term to be sure
and I actually try to stay away from it
in the book the what I what I talk about
in the book mostly is this idea of high
achievement so people becoming great at
stuff becoming really really good at
stuff I don't think it's really
important to make a dividing line some
to try to figure out you know when
you've crossed over into into genius the
point is gathering your resources doing
the best you can pursuing whatever it is
you love to do with with an intensity
and a resilience and a passion and and
just going as far as you can possibly go
we've been living with this myth for
about a hundred hundred and fifty years
going back to the time of Darwin
although I'm not blaming Darwin for this
all they've if the blame resides
anywhere it's really with Darwin's
cousin Francis Galton and we can get
into that if you like but so the idea is
that we we think that its nature versus
nurture that there's there's genes that
that have all this information that kind
of want to push us in a certain
direction and then there's the
environment which is nurture which is
which is obviously different and kind of
an opposing force and and it's kind of
either/or and there's all these studies
that are constantly trying to figure out
well how much is nature and then add on
to the nurture you know is it 60-percent
nature and 40% nurture depending on what
trait you're talking about well it turns
out that genes don't work that way genes
don't get you part of the way they're
you know to the point you're born or the
point shortly after that or before that
genes are always interacting with the
environment so the new way to think
about this is that it's not nature plus
nurture or nascent nature versus nurture
if anything its nature interacting with
nurture if you have to use those words
so one of the phrases that scientists
are using now is G times e that is
genetics times environment as opposed to
G + E ISM that they call it an additive
model the additive model as well you
have so much inborn intelligence and
then plus what you get in the
environment that would be you know the
nature of plus nurture the new the new
model is you can't separate them you
just absolutely cannot separate the
effects of genes from the effects of the
environment so all we can do of course
is to identify the resources that we
have in our environments and and
maximize them as best as best we can
one of the studies is goes back to 1957
or 58 where these two guys were looking
at at rats that had been genetically
designed the genetically bred that is to
be intelligent and in generation after
intelligent they were incredibly
intelligent in you know is seen in mazes
and things like that so then they wanted
to see well what if you subject them to
different environments extreme
environments like sensory deprivation
kind of thing or extra treats and you
know so-called intellectual stimulation
for rats if you can imagine what that is
basically it's lots of toys and
different textures and sounds and sights
and colors and things like that and they
wanted to see well what's the additive
difference of the environment if you
take these these these mice that have
been bred to be smart compared to these
mice that have been bred to be not so
smart well turns out that when you
subject them to these different
environments actually the mice that are
that have have been supposedly bred to
be unintelligent quite often intersect
with the the intelligence the
performance of the mice that have been
bred to be intelligent and the reason is
that you're getting these interactions
which you couldn't have predicted if you
were looking at the old additive model
of G + E so so that was one of the very
early clues that we're looking at a
whole new model of genes and environment
that it was this interactive model